لم تمنع الاجواء البارده الاف المناصرين
لرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو من
التظاهر دعما له ضد قرار محكمه تركيه قضى
بسجنه لمده عامين وسبعه اشهر وحظره من
العمل السياسي
تظاهره شهدت حضور لرؤساء احزاب المعارضه
تضامن مع امام موجلو
د
باخذ منصب رئيس البلديه الذي صوت الناس له
واراد سجني بالاضافه الى ذلك ادركوا ان
القاضي المحكمه لن يحكم كما يشاءون لذاذا
استبعدوه وجلبوا قاضيا اخر واتخذوا قرارهم
تجمع حضره قاده احزاب الطاوله السداسيه
وجميعهم يمثلون غالبيه المعارضه التركيه
اراد منظمه استعراض القوه في حشد الشارع
وفق ما يراه مراقبون وسط اجواء من
الحاضرين رافضه قرار المحكمه
الاراده الشعبيه ونحن لا نرضى بهذا القرار
السياسي
القرار السياسيه قرار اداره رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول لا قصتهجانا ورفضا من معظم القوى
السياسيه والنقابات والتجمعات المهنيه
فضلا عن حملات تضامن اجتاحت وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
تسير المعارضه في هذه القضيه وفق مسارين
الاول حشد الشارع ضد قرار المحكمه الصادر
بحق رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو
والثاني المضيف اجراءات قانونيه للطعن
بهذا القرار زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول